Film production can be a dangerous business.
As we discussed in our video about 10 Incredibly
Hard to Shoot Movie Scenes, getting the perfect
action shot can sometimes mean pulling off
very risky stunts that have the potential
to go disastrously wrong.
Fortunately most productions will have plenty
of precautions and safeguards in place, which
means that on-set deaths are very rare, but
there are still some famous cases of actors
who died while filming, and others who died
before they could finish their current projects.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Actors Who Died
During A Movie’s Production.
Heath Ledger
The Dark Knight actor Heath Ledger sadly didn't
live to enjoy the critical acclaim and the
Academy Award for Best Supporting Actor that
the role earned him, as he died of an accidental
prescription drug overdose six months before
The Dark Knight arrived in theaters.
The Joker wasn't Ledger's final role, however.
At the time of his death, Ledger was a little
over a month into filming Terry Gilliam's
fantasy film The Imaginarium of Doctor Parnassus,
in which he played a central role.
Following the actor's death, Gilliam came
up with the idea of having Ledger's character
change his appearance, and enlisted the help
of Johnny Depp, Jude Law and and Colin Farrell
to take over the role in scenes that Ledger
hadn't yet got around to filming.
With their help, The Imaginarium of Doctor
Parnassus was completed and became the final
piece of Ledger's legacy.
Jon-Erik Hexum
There's a dangerous misconception that guns
loaded with blanks are harmless, when the
truth is that blanks can do a whole lot of
damage when fired at very close range.
This was the fate that befell Jon-Erik Hexum
on the set of CBS action-adventure series
Cover Up, in which he played a CIA agent working
undercover as a model.
During a filming delay, Hexum began jokingly
playing Russian roulette with a .44 Magnum
loaded with blanks.
The gun was pressed right up against his temple
when it went off, firing the wadding from
the blank into Hexum's skull and causing a
massive brain hemorrhage.
After being declared brain dead, Hexum was
eventually taken off life support.
Brandon Lee
Alex Proyas' vigilante superhero movie The
Crow has become a cult classic since its original
release in 1994, but the film is notorious
for another reason.
Brandon Lee, son of Bruce Lee, played the
movie's main character, Eric Draven, a rock
star who is brought back from the dead to
avenge his own murder and the death of his
girlfriend.
In a scene where Eric returns home to find
his girlfriend being attacked, actor Michael
Massee fired a prop gun at Lee, not knowing
that the prop crew had accidentally left a
fragment of a real bullet inside it.
The bullet struck Lee in the abdomen, and
despite being rushed to hospital and undergoing
six hours of surgery, the wound cost him his
life.
Lee was just 28 years old.
Paul Walker
Paul Walker was a mainstay of the Fast and
Furious franchise from the very beginning,
and his appearances in the movies spanned
over a decade - from his first appearance
in The Fast and the Furious to his final portrayal
of Brian O'Conner in Furious 7.
Two months into production on Furious 7, Walker
was killed when the driver of the Porsche
he was travelling in crashed the car into
a lamp post and two trees at high speed.
Following the accident, Universal put production
on hold to give the cast and crew time to
grieve, and to give director James Wan time
to figure out how to rework the film.
Furious 7 was eventually completed using Paul
Walker's brothers, Caleb and Cody, as stand-ins
for his character, with a combination of camera
trickery and CGI used to complete Brian's
story.
Vic Morrow
Like Brandon Lee and Jon-Erik Hexum, actor
Vic Morrow's death was the result of an accident
on set, which is easily one of the most horrifying
tales in the film industry.
Morrow was filming "Time Out," a segment of
Twilight Zone: The Movie in which a racist
gets a taste of his own medicine when he is
cast back in time and assumes the ethnicities
of those he was prejudiced against.
During a scene in which Morrow's character
finds himself in the Vietnam war, a helicopter
hovering overhead was damaged by nearby pyrotechnic
explosions and crashed, decapitating Morrow
and killing two child actors that he was carrying.
Several people involved in production - including
director John Landis - were put on trial for
involuntary manslaughter, but were ultimately
acquitted.
Oliver Reed
Ridley Scott's historical epic Gladiator won
a handful of Oscars in 2001, including the
award for Best Visual Effects.
Among the visual effects used in the film
were early CGI techniques that completed actor
Oliver Reed's scenes as Antonius Proximo,
the gladiator trainer who becomes a mentor
to Maximus Decimus Meridius.
Reed died of a heart attack towards the end
of filming, and his character's fate was rewritten
so that instead of surviving, Proximo sacrifices
himself in order to buy Maximus time to escape.
To complete his remaining scenes, a body double
was used and a CGI mask placed over the body
double's face to create the illusion of Reed
being present.
It was an Oscar-worthy effect, especially
for the time, and a powerful final role for
Reed.
John Ritter
John Ritter first made a name for himself
as one of the leads on ABC sitcom Three's
Company in the 1970s and 80s, and by the early
2000s had gone from TV bachelor to TV dad
in another ABC sitcom, 8 Simple Rules, in
which he played strict but affectionate father
Paul Hennessy.
During filming of the show's second season,
Ritter fell ill due to a heart defect called
aortic dissection, which was initially misdiagnosed
as a heart attack.
Despite efforts to save him, Ritter died in
a hospital later that day.
His death was written into the show, with
the Hennessy family finding out that Paul
had collapsed while grocery shopping.
Bela Lugosi
Bela Lugosi starred in some of the most famous
horror movies ever made, including Dracula,
White Zombie and The Black Cat, but he died
while filming one of the most infamously terrible
movies ever made: Ed Wood's Plan 9 From Outer
Space.
Well, actually that's not completely accurate.
Lugosi had been filming various random scenes
with Wood for other movie projects, and this
footage was eventually cut into Plan 9.
In order to complete these scenes, Wood hired
his wife's chiropractor, who had no acting
experience and didn't even look like Lugosi,
to stand in for the famous actor by holding
a cape over his face.
It's a bit of a far cry from the technical
wizardry that made the completion of Furious
7 possible, but it's also one of the many
quirks that makes Plan 9 From Outer Space
so… memorable.
Marilyn Monroe
One of the most iconic movie stars of all
time, Marilyn Monroe is known for her roles
in classic comedies films like Gentlemen Prefer
Blondes, Some Like it Hot and The Seven Year
Itch.
Monroe's final film was a romantic comedy
called Something's Got to Give, from which
she was fired after one month of production,
then later rehired with a change of director.
Before filming with Monroe could resume, the
actress died of a barbiturate overdose.
Something's Got to Give was never completed,
though the footage was later pieced together
for a documentary called Marilyn: Something's
Got to Give.
Philip Seymour Hoffman
Philip Seymour Hoffman was a highly respected
actor, who in 2006 won an Oscar for playing
the title role in Capote.
In more recent years, audiences became familiar
with Hoffman as Plutarch Heavensbee, the Head
Gamemaker of The Hunger Games.
Sadly, after decades of sobriety, Hoffman
suffered a relapse into the drug addiction
that had plagued him in his younger years,
and with just a week of filming left on The
Hunger Games: Mockingjay - Part 2 the actor
died after taking a mix of heroin, cocaine,
amphetamines and benzodiazepines.
Director Francis Lawrence decided not to try
and complete Hoffman's performance using CGI,
and Plutarch Heavensbee was instead written
out of the scenes that Hoffman had yet to
shoot.
These are just a few of the more memorable
instances of actors dying midway through production,
but there are more examples out there.
Let us know in the comments which actors you
miss the most, and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos like this one.